windsor s'est parée de ses plus beaux
atours pour accueillir les futurs mariés
drapeau britannique et dessert
commémorative aux abords du château les
vendeurs de souvenirs font des affaires
d'or une comédienne américaine qui
épouse un classe britannique sait ne
soyez allons tutu conte de fées alors
forcément
l'idylle entre megan marco et le prince
harry fait rêver 83 ans ne rateraient
pour rien au monde rater l'événement
avec ce groupe de fans de la famille
royale
ils campent depuis trois jours devant
château et d'orge autres doigts en face
angie wright est convaincu d'avoir
trouvé le meilleur coin de rue elle est
venue de brainfuck en ontario m pour
l'occasion l'histoire qui est en train
de s'écrire dit elle et on a
l'impression d'en faire un peu partie en
étant ici le coût total du mariage n'a
pas été annoncé mais on parle de
plusieurs dizaines de millions de
dollars payés par la famille royale
britannique
les retombées elles pourraient être
phénoménal avec l'afflux de touristes et
la vente de souvenirs
certains avancent même le chiffre de
plus d'un milliard de dollars mais ce
n'est pas le seul impact de ce mariage
car le prince perry connu pour ses
écarts de conduite s'apprête à épouser
une roturière du vieil que lui divorce
il féministe et qui parle fièrement de
ses racines noires signe selon beaucoup
de britanniques que la famille royale
est en train d'évoluer en tout cas
quartiers noirs au sud de londres le
mariage est très bien accueillie par
scott c'est bien pour les noirs les gens
des caraïbes dit jack ibérie parce qu'on
peut s'identifier à elle sa part 30 m
il est à peu près temps qu'il y ait du
sang noir dans la famille royale d'elisa
logan mais peut-être ans
il faut savoir vivre avec son époque et
suivre les valeurs actuelles la société
ajoute t-elle comme tous les autres
clientes ce salon beauté elle sera rivé
devant sa télé pour regarder la
cérémonie samedi
mais pour remonter dans l'estimé de ses
sujets
la famille royale devra sans doute
continuer d'évoluer selon
et sans sondages seul un tiers des
britanniques se disent intéressés par ce
mariage ici jean françois bélanger
radio-canada windsor alors avis aux
intéressés nous vous proposons une
couverture toute spéciale de ce mariage
royal céline galipeau va piloter cette
émission spéciale en compagnie notamment
de jean françois bélanger et de
plusieurs invités en direct alors vous
le voyez à l'écran de mai 6h heure de
l'est très tôt le matin et aussi 19
heures un peu plus tard sur ici r10 et a
les meilleurs moments vous seront
présentés à 15h sur ici radio canada
télé c'est donc à suivre dôme est
difficile à manquer